[Musique]
jean-noël barrot bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue pour le café politique je vous
en prie installez-vous là le café
politique au cours duquel nous parlerons
de vos engagements de votre parcours et
puis forcément aussi un peu d'actualité
vous êtes le député de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines
le vice président de la commission des
finances à l'assemblée membre du modem
et du groupe majoritaire aussi à 2 la
république en marche c'est votre premier
mandat de député vous avez été élu fin
juin 2010 est vous l'avez emporté face
au bo sortant pascal thévenot le maire
de vélizy
avant de parler de l'actualité et de
revenir un petit peu sur les sujets du
jour
quelle image qu elle des souvenirs vous
gardez de cette campagne politique
je crois que ça a été une une campagne
d'abord très enthousiasmant puisque on a
essayé de bâtir sur la victoire est la
promesse d' emmanuel macron qui a
recueilli beaucoup de soutien et
beaucoup d'adhésions auprès des
décideurs et des citoyennes et des
citoyens sur l'ensemble du territoire
national mais en particulier dans les
yvelines
de ce point de vue là c'était vraiment
très enthousiasmant et puis sur le plan
politique je crois que ça a été une
campagne assez digne et que
de part et d'autre et quels que soient
les candidats les débats ont été de très
bonne tenue
vous êtes arrivé dans les yvelines alors
que vous étiez élu en haute loire vous
étiez conseiller départemental c'est
arrivé aussi
pourquoi ce choix départementale assez
naturellement parce que ma vie
professionnelle qui m'avait emmené aux
états unis pour y enseigner l'économie
et la finance m'a ramené à hec où
j'avais été formé et c'est donc là où
j'allais notre analyse noir effet que je
connaissais j'y revenais pour pour pour
y vivre et pour y travailler donc c'est
assez naturellement que j'ai été investi
sur cette circonscription et ce mandat
de député vous aviez aussi envie d'agir
au national cette fois ci oui pour 34
ans gg fortement adhéré à la proposition
de renouveau qu'apporter emmanuel macron
j'ai vu dans son programme présidentiel
un certain nombre d'idées et de valeurs
qui m'était cher et je me suis dit que
c'était vraiment l'opportunité d'essayer
de faire bouger les choses que l on
parle de ce mandat de député peut-être
aussi pour marcher dans les pas de votre
famille on est obligé quand même d'y
revenir un petit peu dans les pas de vos
pairs de votre père et votre grand père
noël barrot votre grand-père était
député de la haute loire jusqu'en 66
votre père jacques barrot a lui aussi
était député de 67 jusqu'à en 2004 on
pourrait aussi s'attarder sur le
parcours de votre père qui est ancien
ministre et de valéry giscard d'estaing
et de jacques chirac
également membre du conseil
constitutionnel que jusqu'à sa
disparition en 2014
c'est lui c'est eux qui vous ont donné
le goût de la politique on parler
beaucoup politique en famille et
j'imagine on parlait beaucoup politique
et c'est vrai qu'il ya dans le
l'engagement de mon grand père
alvaro qui vous la lady a été député à
la libération quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup inspiré parce qu'il fait partie
de cette génération qui dans le le le
silence de la résistance s'est engagé au
service des autres et au risque de sa
vie parfois et c'est dans cette forme de
de générosité et
et d'engagement que j'ai tiré
l'inspiration de ma vocation politique
on parlait donc beaucoup politique avait
des débats agités animé vous partager
leurs idées
rapidement vous avez fait votre vos
convictions politiques vous les avez
forgée avec eux mes convictions
politiques je les ai formé bien sûr dans
le dans mon contexte familial comme
comme chacune et chacun mais aussi
pendant ma formation la formation hec et
puis ensuite ma ma vie professionnelle
aux états unis et mon activité de
chercheur qui m'ont aussi amené à
affiner un certain nombre d'idées que je
me fais sur l'économie sur la politique
sur les politiques publiques et donc
c'est la combinaison des deux choses qui
ont fait ce que fut aujourd'hui vous
avez fait le choix du modem et puis par
extension de la république en marche là
aussi ça s'est fait naturellement le
choix de choix du centre et puis et de
la république en marche ensuite vous
avez tout de suite adhéré à ces valeurs
là et à ce qui était portée par emmanuel
macron oui le modem
c'est bien sûr le parti de françois
bayrou mais c'est aussi l'héritier d'une
tradition politique qui remonte à
l'avant deuxième guerre mondiale et à
laquelle mon grand père a participé mon
père aussi et de laquelle je partage les
valeurs pleinement
elle se retrouve aujourd'hui un peu au
centre de gravité de la majorité
présidentielle qui est plus large
puisque
[Musique]
la république en marche rassemble des
personnalités qui vont bien deux des
républicains puisque ou des anciens
républicains avec bruno le maire etc
jusqu'à des personnalités qui viennent
de la gauche y compris d'anciens
premiers ministres de la gauche donc
donc c'est assez vaste et puis au coeur
de cette majorité il ya il ya la famille
centriste et dont le modem et est une
des figures en tant qu élu modem vous
vous sentez bien au sein de la
république en marche
oui absolument d'abord parce qu'il n'y a
pas vraiment de deux murs entre les deux
il ya la double adhésion qui est qui est
possible parce qu'on a été élu sous la
même bannière qui est la république en
marche et qu' il n'y a pas vraiment pour
moi de distinction dans le projet que
nous portons pour la france vous parlez
de votre votre carrière professionnelle
avec ses enseignements aux états unis ce
diplôme d' hec à jouy en josas aussi
donc pour votre parcours politique
professionnelle pardon vous pensé
reprendre cette carrière professionnelle
où je l ai juste entré parenthèses
aujourd'hui bien sûr elle est entre
parenthèses et je compte bien y
retourner puisque la conception que nous
nous faisons de l'engagement politique
c'est qu'il ne doit pas compromettre
l'engagement dans la vie
d'abord dans la vie familiale dans la
vie personnelle mais aussi dans la vie
dans la vie professionnelle la vie
civile jeu
je dirais et
je continuerai d'ailleurs à donner
quelques heures d'enseignement ici et là
je sais pour garder un lien avec avec
cette discipline qui m'a formé et qui me
plaît beaucoup
aujourd'hui c'est en tant que député que
vous agissez vous avez téléchargé par
bercy de faire des propositions aussi
sur le financement de l'économie pour la
préparation d'un projet de loi comment
s'est passée cette mission mais écoutez
c'était c'était passionnant je dois dire
qu'au départ j'étais j'étais un petit
peu circonspect puisque j'avais déjà
énormément de travail déjà avec la
discussion budgétaire puis avec une
autre mission qui m'avait été confiée
sur la modernisation du parlement et ses
moyens d'évaluation et de contrôle
et puis je me suis dit ce serait
toujours trop dommage de laisser
l'occasion de laisser passer l'occasion
de travailler sur ce sujet puisque c'est
un sujet qui est très proche des 2 mai
sujet de mes travaux de recherche et
donc avec alice zagury qui est la
présidente et fondatrice de
l'accélérateur the family basé à paris
nous avons
mené une large consultation y compris
dans les yvelines auprès de chefs
d'entreprises d'organisations
professionnelles de financeurs
de tout de tout horizon pour essayer de
comprendre quelles étaient les obstacles
au financement et à la croissance des
entreprises et qu'elles étaient aussi
les obstacles à la bonne allocation par
les françaises et les français de leur
épargne et nous avons remis
effectivement juste avant noël une série
de propositions basées sur sur toutes
les idées que nous allons faire remonter
du terrain mais nous avions six semaines
pour le faire c'est déjà bien puisque
c'est tout à fait inédit que qu'un
gouvernement avant de rédiger son projet
de loi confie à des députés le soin de
faire une pré consultation mais on a eu
six semaines et c'était court pour le
faire donc on a fait au mieux on parle
parfois justement de ces tensions entre
députés et gouvernement il ya certains
sujets où tout le monde n'est pas aligné
vous vous le ressentez ou pas puis un
sujet concret dont on pourrait parler
sur le territoire c'est celui de la
ligne 18 aussi un qui aujourd'hui reste
finalement à trancher avec des élus de
terrain vous allez nous dire si vous
défendez cette ligne 18 et puis un
gouvernement qui a peut-être des choix à
faire et peut-être supprimer la ligne
dont 18 de ce super métro wii bleue
la séparation des pouvoirs veut que le
pouvoir parlementaire soin distinct du
pouvoir exécutif et la constitution de
la vème république prévoit que c'est
dans l'ensemble le gouvernement qui est
à l'initiative de la loi et les
parlementaires qu'il a discuté qu'ils
amendent et qu'ils la votent donc
évidemment qu'il ya des discussions et
qu on n'est pas toujours d'accord sur
tout ça a été le cas pendant la
discussion budgétaire ce qui est un peu
nouveau dans la proche dont nous
parlions à l'instant c'est que le
gouvernement a souhaité associer les
parlementaires en amont et de la
rédaction par les ministères donc par
l'exécutif du projet de loi et ça c'est
assez nouveau et concernant la ligne 18
alors que concernant la saq ligne 18
bien sûr éclater mais la ligne 18 est
absolument essentiel pour préserver
l'unité et l'avenir de l'eau lienne le
yen c'est cette opération d'intérêt
national qui va du plateau de saclay
jusqu'à saint quentin et versailles et
qui a qui donne à notre territoire et un
au territoire puisque c'est un
assemblage de territoires une
perspective de très long terme de
développement à la fois sur le du point
de vue foncier du point de vue des
transports du point de vue universitaire
du point de vue des entreprises et tout
ça c'est un équilibre assez fragile et
la ligne 18 en est un des éléments
fondateurs c'en est presque la colonne
vertébrale
donc c'est l'un des éléments importants
sur cette circonscription des yvelines
puisqu'on parlait de vos travaux au
niveau national sur les finances mais
quels sont les autres dossiers sur
lesquels vous vous impliquez au niveau
de votre circonscription
alors l'autre dossier essentiel pour la
circonscription c'est la question du
logement
je dirais que c'est aussi la question
des nuisances sonores notamment dans la
vallée de chevreuse sur laquelle on
travaille mais pour revenir sur la
question du logement parce que là il va
y avoir un texte très important ce
printemps le projet de loi est lent donc
le projet de loi en matière de logement
et nous avons
besoin de faciliter l'offre de logement
pour baisser les prix de l'immobilier et
les loyers pour permettre aux gens
d'être mieux le gia aujourd'hui en
france quatre millions de personnes qui
sont mal logés et la note politique du
logement qui engouffre énormément
d'argent public ne parvient pas à ces
objectifs il nous faut donc la réforme
et au parallèle de ça il ya une pression
très forte qu'ils exercent aujourd'hui
sur le plan réglementaire sur les
communes et notamment les communes de la
vallée de chevreuse en matière de
logement social et nous voulons la faire
en sorte que la loi qui est aujourd'hui
très coercitive soit aussi très
incitatives pour qu'on puisse arriver
aux objectifs plutôt que de pénaliser
les villes y compris des villes comme
versailles qui aujourd'hui doivent
verser de très importante amende
du fait de l'application des
des réglementations il faut basculer nos
pratiques
du coup vers city vers l'incitatif ça
fait beaucoup de travail
est ce que vous pensez déjà un nouveau
mandat de député on l'a pas du tout je
fais tout à l'heure on évoqué le fait
que la philosophie c'était justement de
faire une carrière en politique vous est
fixé une limite
non vous avez raison la philosophie
c'est pas faire carrière en politique et
je dois dire que le
le premier semestre en fin de semestre
d'automne était tellement chargé que les
vacances de noël était bien venu pour
retrouver un peu de temps pour pour la
famille un peu de temps pour soi
vous ne regrettez pas néanmoins votre
engagement politique j'imagine non
puisque moi j'ai eu la chance d'être
très vite impliqué dans des sujets qui
me sont très chers et sur lequel j'ai
une expertise on va arriver à la fin de
cette émission trois derniers questions
habituelles pour le café politique votre
livre de chevet mon livre de chevet
c'est les mémoires de jean monnet
pourquoi parce qu européen convaincu des
européens convaincus mais pas seulement
c'est quelqu'un qui a tout très
nombreuses étapes clés du 20e siècle et
ça a commencé pendant la première guerre
mondiale a su systématiquement trouver
des solutions de consensus
en mettant les bonnes volontés autour de
la table et en innovant et en trouvant
des formes institutionnelles nouvelle
pour répondre à des problèmes qui
paraissent insolubles dernier film au
cinéma
si vous avez eu un peu de temps pendant
les vacances eh bien non je voulais
aller voir la promesse de l'aube
mais j'ai pas eu le temps d'aller le
voir ont peut-être ce sera le prochain
film au cinéma en tout cas et d'un art
question votre chanteurs chanteuses
préférées aux morceaux de musique
oui moi je suis
je suis j'ai un petit faible pour la
musique
pour la musique baroque et donc je
citerai
jaroussky pas parce que je
j'ai une admiration particulière mais
parce qu'ils les yvelinois il vient de
se retrouver et en particulier parce
qu'il a participé avec matthieu chedid
avec m à son dernier album sur le mali
et j'ai été très sensible à leur
collaboration
merci jean noël barrot députés les ive
et d'avoir participé à ce café politique
[Musique]
oui
et